new at 11 it's pretty common to see
ducks and geese in lake communities here
in las vegas many are wild breeds that
can survive but others are domestic
breeds and some in the community believe
they're being dumped sasha loftus spoke
with one concerned neighbor tonight
sasha denise the woman i spoke with has
found several baby ducks hurt or even
killed just this past week she believes
they were dumped and she wants to help
others understand how detrimental this
is
if you've ever been to desert shores in
the northwest valley you've no doubt
seen the ducks i love animals and it's
just
no one cares some are wild but a lot of
them are domestic breeds who have a
harder time surviving this is a
an artificial lake in las vegas
so nothing is natural about this peggy
wang who lives in the area does her best
to look out for these flocks but she
believes people come here to dump
ducklings like this one i found was run
over on the street and one was left
alone a lot of these babies end up dying
many are eaten by other wildlife
so she's begging others to understand
while this kind of environment seems
great
these young birds can't fend for
themselves so if you're unable to care
for them as pets it's best to surrender
them to a shelter just like any other
domestic animal they need to be taken
care of they need
food shelter safety she hopes by sharing
her story she can also promote education
just why can't we all work together as a
community to try and take care of them
and encourage everyone to appreciate
these beautiful creatures it's
respecting another life form
now the desert shores website says that
no one is allowed to feed or handle the
ducks or any animals around the lakes i
did reach out and ask them if they had
any policy regarding dumping animals and
did not hear back in time for this
newscast brian sasha thank you for that
as gas